[موسيقى]
بمثل اي طفل بيحب يلعب باللون بعدها بتبلش
تظهر انه هاي موهبه ولا بس مجرد شي الواحد
بحبه
صار بالنسبه لالي حاجه انسانيه يعني بدي
اكل واشرب وجزء من حياتي بدي ارسم
[موسيقى]
لوحه بتكون جوا المرسب هي مشروع كتير خاص
وكثير فيه هيك حياه بالنسبه لي فيه كتير
روحانيه بس بلحظه بتاخد طريقه والناس
بتشوفها وبتتفاعل معها
في لوحه رسبت فيها امي بدون ما اعرف يعني
انت كنت عم برسم طلعت امي الله يرحمها
يعني بشعر فيها يعني بطاقته فيمكن بحسها
غاليه كتير وقت ما بكون صادق مع عملي قد
ما بحسه عم نوصل للناس
عملت بروفايل لانه بضل التواصل عباره عن
بالسوشال ميديا او بهذول البرامج اللي
ممكن نحكي فيها مع الاشخاص وعم تحكي مع
صوره عم بتكون مشاعر واحيانا عم نتعرف على
صوره ما بتعرف صاحبها الحقيقي وفتره من
الفترات صار ما في لون باللوحه لانه بتشبه
الرمادي يمكن المحيط فينا انحرق والخرا
والدمار
مره بحسك كئيبه مره بحسها عندها امل مره
بتشبه تطوره يمكن الشخصي والنفسي ضمن
الظرف المحيط يلي عم نعيشه
[موسيقى]
مره تنطلع صحراء وشفت شلون الرمل الغطه
هاي اللوحه كيف في ناس البيت هاي اللحظه
هون صدفه ففيها حاله من توثيق الذاكره
توثيق المكان وتوثيقي انا كانسان كنت عايش
بهذا الوقت
[موسيقى]
حتى لما بنكون عم نحكي مع شخص شو ما كان
طبيعه الحديث اللي عم يحكيه عيونه بتفضح
عم يحكي
[موسيقى]
العين بتختصر كل الحكي بالوقت اللي بصير
فيه الكلام عليه مسؤوليه كتير كبيره بتكون
العين عم تحكي القصه كلها
[موسيقى]